now I'd like you to make a prediction in
my left hand I have a basketball in my
right hand a 5 kilogram medicine ball if
I hold them both above my head and then
let them go simultaneously which one
will hit the ground first six years ago
here at the University of Sydney I did
an experiment very similar to this where
I handed out heavy object and a light
object and I asked which one would hit
the ground first tell me which one's
gonna hit the ground first I'm gonna put
my money on the black fella what's your
heart telling you I are getting to go
Joe pasa I'm on the black bonzo yeah
okay it's fun go faster and hit the
ground best pickin son you gonna pick
that way what's your feeling about that
one how does it compare to the well it's
a lot heavier I just feel like the
weight is you know pulling it down you
know the more weight it's the faster
it's gonna fall to the ground the forces
are more on that ball than this one you
can definitely tell the difference I
mean I go to a gym like seven days a
week faster I can still feel it
well that one feels like I could almost
go up where this one is going down it's
got hair so it the flip thing up is
visit us on being pulled out now I think
now you're coming back to me I'm
thinking basketball now what's making
you think basketball because he come
back to me sure I'm just saying like you
know i'ma stay so you can't corrupt me
obviously I saw on a black alright let's
actually do this thing so you want to
hook us up as high as you can and the
key is to be as simultaneous as you can
all right you ready
can I count it down yeah three two one
Zachary's oh three two one
yes we did what did you think happened I
feel a black one went first we've got
the black one later at first he'd have
to go to the tape what did you see they
looked like that pretty much land at the
same time same thing at the same time I
thought it's very closest place to basic
in it it's good so it's not a very high
distance sorry
they haven't really reached their
maximum velocity yet Oh the blackboards
didn't reach terminal velocity wasn't
enough time for it to fall I would
thought it'd be like with a different
variables like um so like that one had
to like right boom here whatever break
more air the answer is
although the force of gravity on the
black ball is greater it has a greater
mass and therefore greater inertia so it
requires more force to accelerate it
there's less gravitational force on the
basketball but because it's mass is
lower it has less inertia and therefore
requires less force to accelerate it at
the same rate as the medicine ball let's
give it a try three two one